[Music]
consider the given triangular Channel
this is a concrete lined channel that is
designed for a maximum flow of 5 cubic
feet per second its length is500 ft and
it has a vertical slope of
2% if the flow is 3 cubic feet per
second what is the critical depth in
feet in this problem we are given a
triangular Channel and are asked to find
the critical depth at a given flow rate
first things first let's search the
manual for critical depth the first
occurrence will take you to a section on
rectangular channels let's skip this and
find the one for triangular channels we
can keep clicking through results for
critical depth until we come to the
section
6.4.5 point4 titled flow in channels the
second page of this section leads to the
channel section critical
depths if we look at the part of the
table that deals with triangular
cross-sections we can see that the
equation for critical depth is given as
follows y Sub C equals theare < TK of 2
* Z Sub C / Z all of which is raised to
0.4 note that zc in this equation is the
critical flow section
factor in general a section factor is a
ratio involving area with or other
geometric
properties the critical flow section
Factor Z subc is a parameter that helps
us to determine the critical depth Y
subc in a channel it is based on two
geometric properties the flow area and
the top
width this is a product of the wed
perimeter and the square root of the
hydraulic depth not that you need to
know any of this to actually solve this
problem what you do need to know is that
there is an equation for Z subc in the
table as well however we can't use it
since we don't have the depth instead we
have to use the general equation at the
top of the table to solve for it since
we have flow and know what gravity is
the equation to use is going to be as
follows Z subc equal Q over theare < TK
of
G so the information we need from this
problem includes the side slopes and the
flow rate the other information provided
includes the max design flow rate the
vertical slope and the length of the
channel none of these are needed to
solve the problem
so first we can solve for the critical
flow section Factor where Q
equal 3 cubic feet per second and G is
going to be the square OT of 32.2 ft
perss
squar and we can see that Z
subc solves to
0.53 Ft raised to the
2.5 note that the units of this
answer our feet raised to the 2.5 not
the whole
number this will make sense once the
problem is
solved then we can plug this back into
the equation for critical
depth note that multiplying the
exponents on the units together gives us
a final unit of feet once
again
so solving for y Sub C we can see that
the square root
of
2 * 0.53 solved for
before over the Z
value which according to our table is
the horizontal component to the slope
which is going to be
three and all of this raised to the
0.4 and we can see that this calculates
out to 0.57 Ft
and that's all it takes to solve this
problem